- Hey, how y'all doing?
- Kelly!
- [Kelly] Hi, how are you doing?
- Good, how you doing, girl?
- Oh my gosh, hello to both of you.
How are you?
- Good!
- I am such a big fan of both of you,
so I'm so happy you're both doing my show.
I think you're both hysterical.
So this podcast is somewhat, you know,
kind of bringing you back to your roots
because you were both on
radio together, right?
- Yes, we did...
the "Tom Joyner Morning Show" together.
- "Tom Joyner Morning Show"
together for almost four years.
And we had such a chemistry.
And all that time I said, "Kim,
we should just do a podcast
because we love to talk."
Like we talk three times a day,
and I said, "It'd just
be so funny just to talk
about stuff that we know about."
You know, raising kids, our relationships
or lack thereof, and everything.
So we started this podcast,
we financed it ourselves,
nobody's helping us.
- Wow!
We do microphones, lights,
makeup and everything.
- Yeah!
- Yeah, she kept, she
kept, she kept saying,
"We need to do a podcast together.
We need to do a podcast together."
And I just, I was dragging
my feet, but now I love it!
- Yeah, but that's 'cause
you get to sit home
in your pajamas.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, that is true.
I love being at home.
- I love that too.
- I know, I don't like Zooming like this
like in a sense that you
miss the energy of the show,
or even as a singer, like being on stage,
but I do love the fact
that I'm wearing flip flops
with this cute little number,
the dress I'm wearing.
I'm like, and you can't
see the bottom half of me.
That's the best part of
this job right now. (laughs)
- Oh, absolutely.
I've jumped up and I
forgot I had on shorts.
Like I had a pretty top on.
I've jumped up and Sherri's
done the same thing!
And I was like oh!
I was like oh, don't do that again.
- I do, I have on shorts right now.
My pajama bottoms.
'Cause I'm going to bed
- Oh my gosh!
when I get done.
- I love it.
Hey, why not? They can't see it.
Well, until you pop up.
So you got the idea for the podcast though
from when you would try
to one-up each other
with celebrity name drops, right?
- Yeah, because we were talking
because we started Two Funny
Mamas podcast just to talk,
but when we were talking,
we realized we knew a lot of celebrities.
Like for me, I knew Prince
because I got to get on stage
at Madison Square Garden
and dance with Prince.
- What?
- Oh, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
See, that doesn't even rate.
Prince invited me to his house.
And I was at a Anita Baker concert,
and Anita brought me on stage to sing
the whole last half of her song.
So that's-
- What?
- Excuse me, but do you know the song
"You Give Good Love to Me?"
- Uh huh.
- I helped Anita Baker write that.
- No, no, no, Megan Thee Stallion,
I was in the studio,
and when she was writing
"I'm a Savage", it started
off as I'm a Sammich,
and I told her that doesn't sound right.
- (laughing) I love you two.
- You were with Megan Thee Stallion
when she wrote I'm a,
and it was supposed to be I'm a Sammich?
- Yes. Yes. Yes.
- Classy, bougie, ratchet?
- I helped Jermaine Jackson,
you remember the song,
Kelly Clarkson, "Let's get Serious?"
Let's get serious.
- Yes, yeah.
I helped him write
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah."
That was me.
- No, no, no!
- That was my one
for one-third.
- When Kelly Clarkson,
- No, no, no.
Kelly Clarkson asked me to do
the Country Music Awards with her.
I had to turn her down
(Kelly laughing)
'cause I was homeschooling.
- She was like, nah,
Kelly Clarkson's not
cool enough to work with.
- I was behind the
scenes on "American Idol"
when Kelly was on there,
and I was like, girl, go deeper.
Go lower. Go in. Don't bash it, Simon.
- I wrote "A Ribbon in the Sky."
for Stevie Wonder.
- I wrote. (laughs)
- I wrote "A Ribbon in the Sky." (laughs)
I'm back with the Two Funny Mamas,
Sherri Shepherd and Kym Whitley,
and that was a clip from
Sherri's Netflix series,
"Mr. Iglesias."
You can watch those episodes
streaming right now.
But Sherri, okay, you play
a principal in this show,
and I understand you
now have some experience
as a real life educator.
- Well, you know, Kim and I,
we both are teachers to our sons.
We're both like homeschool teachers.
You know, I wanna bow
down to every educator.
- Amen.
- I really didn't know
my son was like this.
Half the time, I don't
know what Joshua does, Kim,
but he'll be having a history lesson,
like, he'll be doing this.
- It's so annoying!
And I'm like just do it and it'll be done!
- That's what she says to
Joshua all the time, don't you?
Just do it, it'll done.
- Just do it.
And no, no, no, Sherri already knows.
I had to go to the doctor because
the homeschool has stressed me out.
I had heart palpitations.
I couldn't...
I couldn't get the work in,
I didn't know how to scan it in,
the teachers were like,
"Where's the work?"
And then, it's too much. It was too much.
- What gave me heart palpitations
is Ny squared equals Pi.
I said pie I know, 'cause I eat that,
but all that math and geometry,
that ain't my from the CLO.
- So a lot of people are
trying to take this time
to get in shape.
I am not one of them, but
there are people I hear of.
So Kim and Sherri,
how have you guys been
staying healthy in quarantine?
- Well, I am happy to say for me,
I was lucky that I am the new ambassador
for WW, which was
formerly Weight Watchers.
Thank you, Sherri.
- Yes.
- Yeah!
- I'm very excited about that.
It came at the perfect time
because I literally was,
at the beginning of this,
I was eating, I was
eating, I was watching TV,
eating, cooking and
teaching and everything
and just stressing out.
But now that I'm on WW,
I am now 18 pounds down.
- Wow!
So you're good with the numbers.
Like counting, you're good with all that.
- Yeah.
I didn't think I could do it
'cause I've never done it before,
- Yeah.
- But that app and Weight Watchers has,
I mean, oh, I mean WW,
formerly known as Weight
Watchers, has really...
I'm talking about it saved me, Kelly.
It really has saved me.
- And that 18 pounds you lost
- Hey, anything that helps.
is on my body, I gained it all.
- Well Sherri's upper body is very strong.
- I started a push up challenge
with all my girl friends
where we were doing,
we were getting in 50 push ups in 30 days.
And this is so everybody
had to send in a video
of their push ups, and we
were, we almost got to 50.
Kim sent me the video
recently, she did three.
(Kelly laughing)
And then I couldn't post it, Kelly,
'cause she didn't have her hair on.
- Good Lord, okay.
Well, I understand Kim,
you're dating as well.
How are you dating during this time?
- Oh, honey, it is the best thing.
I mean, this COVID thing
is of course a curse,
but a blessing at the same time
because what I have found out
is that since we had this,
you can date men, you don't
have to sleep with them,
you get to know them.
They don't have to see what you have on
on the bottom 'cause
you meet him in your car
six feet away.
They don't know that you
haven't washed in days.
It is so good.
- They can't smell you?
They can't smell you, and
you get to know each other.
So it's been good for me because I go on
these social distancing dates
that either we're at the park,
we're far away, or we're,
you know, in a car.
So we don't have to touch each other,
and then I can make a
decision if I like you or not.
I just, I don't revert
- It's kind of a
to my own ways.
- really great thing,
- 'cause then you find out if
you actually really like them.
- Thank you.
- Yeah!
- I got these lips for a reason,
and I wanted to kiss somebody.
- No, but can you imagine the tension?
Like the buildup?
That's gonna be amazing.
Like when you can't touch each other,
you can't see each other
and you're talking it out
and you're like just
woo, it's gonna be good,
and then it happens?
- I want a man that-
- It's gonna be that!
No, I want your tat.
I want your COVID test tattooed on your,
like on your, the negative result,
and I just want, that's what I want.
I wanna kiss your negative COVID tattoo.
(Kelly laughing)
- Sherri has a, Kelly,
Sherri has a mask with a flap
so she may,
(Kelly laughing)
- It lifts.
Okay.